we're about to make a start if we can
have your attention please
um welcome to this meeting with bab
planning committee I will now ask the
governance officer to read out the D
domestic arrangements and the fire
regulations thank you
Elicia thank you chair uh please ensure
that microphones are turned off when not
in use please do not interrupt other
speakers or hold separate conversations
whilst others are speak speaking if you
are attending the meeting to speak and
persistently interrupt the meeting you
may be asked to leave please ensure that
your mobile phones are on silent or
switched off and that your laptop is
also switched to silent I would like to
remind everyone present that this
meeting will be broadcast live to the
internet and will be capable of repeated
viewing the whole of a meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items if you make
a representation to the meeting you will
be deemed by the council to have
consented to being recorded by entering
this meeting as a speaker you are also
consenting consenting to being recorded
by the council and to the possible use
of those sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes the council
members of the public and the Press May
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public impress and not
lawfully
excluded fire safety Arrangements if you
hear the fire alarm leave the building
immediately VI a fire exit and make your
way to the assembly point which is on
ipswitch toown football
ground follow a science Direction you to
the fire exits at the end of each floor
do not enter the atrium the ground floor
area and walkways if you are in the
atrium at the time of the alarm follow
the sence to the nearest fire exit use
the stairs and not the lifts and please
do not reenter the building until you
are told it is safe to do so thank you
chair area planning manager Mark Russell
legal adviser and de prey two case
offers Bradley and Jasmine and Alicia
you've met apologies for absence and sub
stitution thank you chair we have
apologies from councelor Margaret M and
councelor Peter beer and we have
councelor Paul Clover substituting of
councelor beer this morning and
councelor
Carter councelor Carter is on her way
but she's advis she will be about 10
minutes late so she should arrive at bit
lat thank you very much to receive
Declarations of disclosable peuli
interest and other registerable and
non-registered interests by members are
there any to declare
Council register yes I I have to declare
that I used to I'm a member of bvw
Action Group uh which was a campaigning
group for Belleview Park but we never
considered this planning
application uh and or commented on it as
a group um and also I was present when
sub Town Council planning um highways
and development committee considered
this planning application but I have no
pecuniary
interest
let's just switch on that's that's a
council register spoke to me before the
meeting I that's as far as I'm concerned
that's fine that's a non registerable
interest that does not affect the
councilor's uh right and ability to vote
on speak on this
matter councelor gron do you have a
interest uh I don't think I need to
State this but just to be clear um I I
know the owner of bellev house so I
don't think it's anything I've got no
pear interest great thank you at least
I've mentioned it thank you you
councelor
H yeah I was Cabinet member of the
economic development team uh early on in
the Belleview scheme of part of which
was the uh proposed Cafe but this is
slightly different design Etc but I just
want to declare
that thank
you Declarations of
lobbying no Declarations of personal
site visits I suppose this a difficult
one not to personally sign visit
subject no all right thank you very
much we move
on confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting meeting held on the 13th of
December I refer the members to the
minutes as published in the table papers
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the
minutes all I say is they're quite brief
and I'm not sure they actually give a
very detailed um review of the meeting
but uh if everyone's happy with them I
can see no issue and uh I'm happy to
propose they are accepted as they
written thank you have a propos it can I
have a second councelor Osborne thank
you conduct a vote thank you chair
members that vote is now in
progress
thank you chair that makes eight votes
for and one exstension those are carried
all right thank you I will sign them in
a
moment receive notification of petitions
do we have any uh n Reed Che thank
you site
inspections I hand over to the to Mark
and Jasmine you like to thank you chair
we have a request from Council Derek
Davis um for a site visit relating to
application DC
23419 the former Gangi site of
shley Jasmine is here to explain
[Music]
is that skipped a
slide uh yeah it was I think
yeah
oh didn't realize that was
there okay perfect um so the application
is a section 73 application which seeks
to vary uh previously approved plans at
the former HMS Gangi site in shle Gate
um the applications is are likely to
come to committee for determination
until March probably at the earliest
just for
background um so in terms of planning
history on the site I think this is
probably quite an important thing to
touch on um some members may remember
going out on site a number of years ago
um the original application that this
seeks to vary is actually from
2015 um in terms of the changes on the
site um the site is actually now
currently under construction um there
are some units that have been occupied
there's been a roundabout that's put in
and um the swimming pool has actually
now been listed as well um so there's
some of the the kind of more recent
contextual
changes um so a number of changes are
actually proposed under this application
which are listed on the screen um I'll
give you a minute just to kind of run
through those um it's quite extensive as
you can see there is an uplift in the
number of dwellings on site so an
increase of 18 um we've got some changes
in some of the existing buildings in
terms of their uses uh this is to
improve some of the viability uh issues
on the
site um there are as as you can see a
range of uh different various bits and
pieces including alteration to internal
Road layout as well well uh removing
connections to King Edward uh fifth
drive drive and uh basically to provide
emergency vehicle access um as
well
is everyone happy for me to move on or
do you still everybody read
them yes y um so this is the the site
location plan as you can see there are a
number of existing buildings within the
site um most of which are well either
they're to be demolished or kind of
repurposed and
converted um and then these are the site
plans so we've got one that just kind of
shows the the ground floor areas and
then one that's the the roof plan but
hopefully between the two um it's quite
clear so in terms of uh the requested
site visit uh the site visit has been
requested on the basis that the site
remains controversial since it gained
planning permission in 2015 we've had a
number of objections um coming in uh
it's an important strategic site in
babber uh there's a benefit for members
to see existing buildings which have
been referred to extensively by historic
England and the council's Heritage team
because the site does fall um wholly
within the conservation area and a
number of buildings as I mentioned are
listed as well um this is basically a
chance to see the site as a whole and in
perspective uh to understand the
difficulties with viability and the
surrounding Road Network um which are
two of the the kind of key elements
driving this
forward thank you for
listening thank you Jasmine any
questions for the
officer Council Hall we'll kick off for
you so the last map of the two plans
were they the same you said one was
ground floor one was second uh so one is
the the roof plan differences that are
proposed in the amendment that that's
the amended proposed site plan but it
sorry the two that was shown one was
just kind of the ground floor one's a
roof plan but that was what is being
proposed amendment but how different is
that to what the original plan was in
terms of layout
changes uh I can I can certainly try and
find
one um see if I
can this might take me a little bit of
time so I don't know if there are any
other questions and I'll come back to
it
councelor
Grand thank you it it's possible that I
might be saying something similar to my
colleague um in that if if we visit will
we be showing the sort of differences
because I I was one of the original
2015 um people who went on the original
site visit will we be showing the
difference between what was then
proposed and what is now proposed thing
not just what is now proposed yeah we
can we can certainly have um a kind of
pack for members that shows the kind of
difference in in plans that's that's not
a problem I think that's fairly routine
with a lot of the walk around and shown
yes otherwise if we're just shown apart
might as well do it here yes yeah no in
terms of so um as I say the the
development well the site is an active
construct construction site at the minut
so it's likely that the developer will
be will be a able to kind of guide some
of the
um well I suppose what has specifically
changed and show and kind of point out
the the specific changes um but
obviously as per the earlier slide
there's there's quite a lot so some of
it is some of it's a lot more minor than
some of the other bits but some of it
it's fairly fundamental in terms of you
know obviously we've they've now had a
listing been put on the buildings so
some of the changes internally as well
are things that will will come out as
well as actually external layout
changes any other
questions I've got one when's this
likely to come to
committee I would suspect probably March
time early or
late I'm going to push you there
because um I'll say late okay it gives
us more time and better weather to get
out on a a site visit
well I was going to say we can bundle
you all into a coach and take you out
this
morning that will so be roll
up thank you any more
questions no and
then can I have a proposal or a
second can speak cuz he was the one that
called it in I assume so it would be
nice to hear from the Ward members to
Ely there isn't anything in the
Constitution that allows him to speak at
this time I think if you've got a
question for him I might be able to
persuade him to answer the question
councelor Davis why did you call it
in thank
you Char the other
one this one's come on so I press that
button and this one came on so yeah the
reason I call it in councel Hall is uh
as as the officer has very eloquently
put um it is a major strategic site for
Baba and I think many of you the
counselors have not visited um this site
especially with the new application
coming in there's a lot that you will
find uh interesting and useful as has
been pointed out it is slightly
different to the original application
the important thing I think as well is
for you to be able to see on site and
and and I've been on the site recently
you will be able to walk around some of
the buildings that are affected by
Heritage um those listed buildings you
will be able to see the state of
disrepair or or otherwise um and just
get a general feeling for the spne road
for where the retail unit is going to be
and just everything actually on site it
is a hugely important um site and uh and
it it will it will benefit you
enormously when it it comes to um
listening to the application in due
course thank you councelor
grandon um can I ask is it all one
application so there was a big long list
there of aspects so if we felt
comfortable with some aspects but not
with others would we have to approve the
whole lot you know so is it all one
application or or you can you tell me
how how it will work please so in terms
of obviously this is just for the site
visit at the minute but in terms of the
application itself it is it is a case of
obviously you have to look at the whole
application as a whole we're not picking
out specific Parts um that may be
something that members debate and decide
that there are certain things they're
happy with and certain things they're
not happy with when it comes to planning
committee but for the time being we're
just looking at a potential site it I
think I agree with Jasmine's quite right
and it's it is essentially an All or
Nothing thing when you make it when in
committee you make your final decision
it's split planning inspectors sometimes
make split decisions as we know but we
committees very rarely do and it's of
raises legal
issues thank
you any more comments questions from
anyone Council hold we got the
picture try to find
it okay well while we're waiting we'll
direct the questions to
Mark is there another planning
application in shley that might benefit
from a site visit at the same
time
there is another application at the
moment for I think it's um and again
Jasmine will know this she's the case
officer I think um could you explain I
think it's 11 units isn't
it yes so there is there is another um
application to the south of the site
which is along the shotly marina um that
is again section 73 but all they are
seeking to do is relocate uh 10 of the
units elsewhere in the
site can I ask counc Davis
there's any significance of trying to
visit that or is that just
straightforward it is as the officer
says it's pretty straightforward um you
will be able to see if if you have the
site visit when you go down to the
bottom part of of the Gangi site you
will be able to see where it connects up
to the the marina side um but I don't
think you would gain anything more by
visiting the marina if you like
additionally because you'll be able to
see it from the Gangi site anyway it's
just if we go
want to try make the best use of that by
time yeah because um as Jasmine says
it's a relocation of the houses away
from a sensitive
um Landmark um which is been asked for
by English Heritage so it's that so you
and again you'll be able to see it from
the Gangi
side thank you councelor hold have you
got your picture
yet I'm minded to say no um um I don't
see enough detail in front of us today
to Warrant us going out on site if there
was an officer Report with a lot more
detail with officer recommendations and
also Heritage reports on as to whether
these buildings are going to be impacted
or whatever then I would possibly review
that decision but from what I'm seeing
today I don't see that what I'm
presented with warrants a site visit if
down the
line the the more details come
forward then I can see Poss possibly
there might it might warrant it but as
it's being presented today I don't see a
site visit is going to do anything for
me to make decision on the information
that's been presented to me today so I
would say propose that we do not go on a
site visit at this time okay is there a
second for that councelor Osborne thank
you do you want to speak or
you you must probably one of The
Originals thank you thank you Mr
chairman yes I was and I think it was
three visits I've had there so I agree
with Council H there's no reason that as
far as I can see of actually having the
uh problem of of driving down there if
there is a problem but um yeah I agree
there's enough there for us to uh as
councelor H said if if there was more
sort of detailed stuff from the officer
and no reflection on what she's been
saying uh yeah I would I would tend to
have another visit but as far as I can
see I think there's enough information
there thank you park that for a moment
counc grandon you want to comment or ask
another
question um sorry I disagree with my
colleagues I I think there's so much
there and it's such an important
strategic site um I I attended in 2015 I
can't remember with end again um but I
would I think we do need a site
inspection
thank you councelor Davis you want to
make well obviously
sorry wrong councelor Davis Sor the
female one don't be too Keen Derek yeah
um speaking as a new counselor and just
what I've heard on this particular site
I I would welcome a site visit because
I've not seen it and it is a big site it
is contentious and we had another
application on shle not that long ago
um which dredged up some objections that
I suspect will be applied to any further
objections for the gandes one just just
for my personal perspective I would like
to see it and the other two are a bit
more experienced than me and they've
already seen it but I would welcome it
can we do a partial site
visit I'm trying to get you to do two or
three while you're there but um any
other comments before we take a vote on
on councelor
Wyman thank you chair I agree with my
colleague I'd like to see I mean I think
there's a range of new counsels that
really haven't seen the site generally
anyway so I think that would help us to
have some real perspective on the on the
overall
situation do you think you've been given
sufficient information now
to sorry j I think it'd be really useful
also to have some further information
prior to the site visit so we can we can
contextualize the whole process thank
you Council hold uh just to clarify have
not into Gangi site
before I think there's only two of you
that have that's Katherine and and
Adrian even I haven't been there well
not to look at a planning
application um okay so there's a
proposal on the table I suppose we take
a vote by hand or you want
electronically electronically we have a
vote proposed by Council Holton proposed
by secondly by Council Osborne that we
don't have a site visit so we've got to
have a formal vote on
that a yes vote is a vote for not having
a side visit then
yeah thank you chair members that vote
is now in
progress
thank you chair so that makes three
votes for a proposal and six votes
against that is lost so that's lost
now can I have a
proposal can I have now a proposal for
aight visit councelor Davis secondly
councelor
grandon anybody wants to make any more
comments before we have another
vote
no sorry is there a date in mine Mr
chairman I would like to suggest we need
it needs to be as close as it can be to
to to when the the planning application
comes to here because as I understand it
it's an ongoing site so we could go
tomorrow and there could be a complete
change by the end of March when when
this might come to us so I think we we'd
have to be a little bit fluid I hate to
say this because it cause problems of
Mark a little bit fluid in our approach
to this one and it might be that that it
has to be done
not a a day notice but but but
relatively short notice sort of
situation when we when we know that the
application has been
submitted
okay also when you want to tie into the
uh site visit for shortly the 11 units
there well from what I can hear that
would only be incidental at this
particular
stage but it can be done at the same
time yeah councel hope just pick it up
what you said chair I think the later
the better the more detail that's
available to members when they visit is
the key because what we've seen today is
just headlines and let's no meet on the
bone on them okay
so Jasmine you're you're you're very
much in the situation where you'll keep
me and the other members of the
committee appraised of when it of its
progress and when it might come to us
yes yeah and I think possibly if if
members would like a rough indication
possibly sometime early March I would
say for the site visit either side of
the
planning we have planning committee two
planning committees for March so you we
want it between them yeah that that
would most probably be a rough estimate
at this particular
time chair um if we're looking at
bringing this um late March obviously
that might change um our last Committee
in March is the
usually we do uh if this goes through
usually we do a site visit for a week
before the committee where it's being
considered so it would likely be the
13th if we work into those dates but um
I'll work alongside Mark and Jasmine to
get that timed and I'll try and let
members know as far in advance as
possible should this go through okay so
we have a proposal in a second are there
any more comments to be made before we
go to this
vote no so let's make it plain you are
voting for a site visit if you vote for
this
motion thank you chair members that vote
is now in progress for
you
thank you chair that makes six votes for
the proposed and three votes against
that site visit will be put in motion
pass okay so we'll be having a site
visit in sounds like the middle to late
part of
March so don't book any more holidays
from
March thank
you thank you Jasmine thank you
Mark um we'll now move on to the
planning applications if you're all okay
no problems right
um excuse me chair may I fortunately we
we now have councelor Cara with us can
we just check that the council doesn't
have any declarations that would have
been made at the beginning of declar Y
thank you
um yeah um I feel I should declare that
I'm a a Town and County counselor for
sub where BW is B comes under your
county does County and town yeah but
there's no pecuniary interests uh no
thank you thank you thank
you moving on then establish that
to DC
2353 Belleview Newton Road sub
suffk um I will just move straight to
Bradley and ask him to introduce the
application to the committee all your
Brad thank you chair good morning
members um the application you're being
asked to consider this morning is a full
application uh for the erection of a new
Cafe building and replacement toilets uh
Belleview Park and
SRE um and an Associated outside seating
area to serve the cafe
this slide excuse me this slide shows
the site uh it's an aerial view um
which for uh context um this is the the
main area of of bellev Park you can see
here um the the building with the Red
Dot on top of it is Belleview house um
and another notable feature when you
visit the park Park is the site the
former open air swimming pool the
application site we're talking about is
here the other feature you will note
from the um aerial photograph is the
amount of established trees on site
which obviously is a a valuable
feature this is the site location plan
um with the site Edge red
um the other thing you will note from
the area that's being you're being
considered today that includes the the
area for the site of the proposed
building but also includes the existing
WC's uh which are proposed to be
demolished as part of this
proposal this constraints map shows the
location site um in relation to subre
Conservation Area um and and also the
listed buildings the site itself as you
will know is not adjacent but the park
obviously is um if you've had the
benefit of walking through the park
you'll have noted the Topography of the
site um and in terms of the position of
the site in relation to the conservation
area we're comfortable as officers that
the actual site itself doesn't impact on
the character of the conservation area
admittedly the wider bellw Park um is
adjacent
the building Belleview house itself is
locally listed um it's not got a a
statutory list but it's on the local
list for
subre this is the red line site which
basically shows the footprint of the
building that's being proposed and again
just to quickly point
out the toilet block immediately
adjacent the Blue Line there shows the
extent of land that is under the
ownership or control of the
council this is the proposed plans and
elevations of the building as you can
see it's a contemporary building it's a
a sectional construction so a lot of the
construction will take place offsite um
and the final construction take place on
site the uh the building itself will sit
on the existing hard stand area which is
in the park
already um and it in terms of the the
materials it's got a steel wall but it's
CL steel walls but it's clar with Timber
um and the the windows and doors are
aluminum and it's got a flat roof as
well as you
note this is a larger uh plan of the
proposed floor area um of the building
it can fundamentally be split into three
areas um what you have in this area here
if you can see my cursor is the public
area which is the the cafe area with
obviously Associated
seating the L-shaped part of the
building you can see there is the
kitchen and the servery facing onto the
uh the cafe
area um and then this large this last
portion of the building is the
replacement WC facilities to serve the
park um and you'll see that it's four
WC's there and there's also a larger DDA
Compliant toilet facility um and also
changing Place facility within that
particular part of the
building these are some CGI views of the
proposed building as you can see again
just to emphasize it
its contemporary appearance which I've
discussed in the
report that's the rear that's facing
south onto the
boundary um that's the entrances to the
new
WC's um and that's the flat roof that
doesn't show the PV that would be
secured by condition uh to be added to
the building as part of the the overall
sustainable construction approach that's
been taken um I'll finish off with some
photographs this is the building that's
to be replaced uh to be demolished um
and as I've said in my report it's
important to note that the land that
sits on will actually be returned back
to Parkland so um in terms of the mppf
advice about loss of Parkland um we're
content that this approach um meets the
requirements the
mppf you can see the established tree
immediately to the South and if I show
you the
next uh slide that uh hard standing you
see there will remain there's no
proposals to excavate um so therefore
the the actual tree roots uh that may
project under that area uh will be
undisturbed it will sit on top the
building will sit on
top this is the remainder of the hard
standing area where the building would
sit on
um and the outdoor seating area which
would which would um relate to the
building would be provided on the
remainder of the hard standing that you
see
there this is a a distance view of the
overall site for the proposal so the
building we're talking about will
sit approximately in this
location um in terms of an overall
development um um in planning terms as I
said in the report we are comfortable
with the approach that's taken um the
architectural approach um and the fact
that it's providing uh replacement
toilet facilities which I understand are
subject to repeated vandalism and also a
cafe facility which doesn't exist in the
park at the moment in the form proposed
um there positives which meet with the
aspirations I think of the the jlp
policies in relation to this particular
sort of development
so on that basis uh a positive
recommendation is made to committee
thank
you thank
you any questions for the officer
please hang on councelor
grandon thank you chair um yes uh you
mentioned vandalism and that was one of
my big concerns on reading the
report um vandalism of L in particular
The Changing Places
facility and also um graffiti and that
kind of thing on the outside of the
building um can you tell me
how um these things how vandalism has
been prevented in the design of these
building
ke um well I can't sit here and say that
the building wouldn't be vandalized the
new building in the same way as any
other structure may be vandalized within
the park
unfortunately um and I'm not going to
come up a try answer and say it's not
really a planning issue but if it's an
issue of being uh maintained properly um
my colleagues in the public realm team
will have that
responsibility um and there are elements
within the building such as lighting
which one would hope would be um able to
restrict vandalism and obviously the the
building itself rather than Standalone
toilets which is the case at the moment
is associated with an area that would be
publicly accessible for a lot of the
time whilst the toilets are being used
so that in itself may act as a as as a
way of trying to stop that but um I
can't as I said I can't I can't actually
promise it won't be vandalism
yeah because I know there is a lot of
vandalism in this park um so are the
materials that are being used for the
outside of the building of the type that
you can't
um um do graffiti on them I know there
are materials that can be used for such
facilities um that are espcially you
know made so that they are less likely
to be graffi they're not graffiti proof
but they are less likely to um enable
graffiti to be done easily um which you
know just looks ugly doesn't it and and
would prevent cause a lot of work for
our teams um so is are the materials
used of the type that makes graffiti
difficult to
do the material that's proposed um at
this stage is Timber
the treatment of the Timber hasn't been
addressed or conditioned in the
application um you're right in terms of
the the
treatment um I think that if members
felt it was
appropriate in terms of the color the
final finish um and the use of the
material applied to the timber itself in
order to to be easier to clean for
example I think that that's something
that could be conditioned as part of the
overall approval but we haven't got that
detail at this
stage so chair may we um can I make a
suggestion of we we have a
representative of Buc Lee caral here as
the agent perhaps we'd be better off
asking him some of these questions yes
when we get round to his turn in a
little while okay if if you're happy
with that can and then we can see
whether you need anything yes thank you
I'd be happy with that thank you thank
you very much
go through a hold in the I think it's
slide seven that there are no internal
toilets for
staff is that a deliberate obviously
it's deliberate but is that a sensible
approach so that staff when working have
to go outside round to the side of the
building to the toilet or what was the
idea behind that in truth counselor it's
what what we've been considered in in
planning is the floor space that we've
been given in terms of the internal or
organization of it um there is no link
between the D the WC's and the cafe
itself so as a customer or working in
the cafe you'd have to to walk out a
door and go around the side um I'm I
haven't been party to the discussions
about the internal Arrangements in that
respect so I don't know I don't I don't
think it's it's deemed to be
particularly inconvenient for users of
the toilets and the cafe to have to do
that but it's not again not something
that we've been asked to consider as
part of the plan application so what we
see in front of us is actually what will
be
delivered and that does not include a
toilet for staff that's correct yes yeah
interesting perhaps yet again you might
like to ask that
question have
believe councilor
Clover thank you chair um I'm not sure
if this is the right question for you it
might be elsewhere but in terms of costs
pre previous planning applications have
been um revised shall we say because of
the rising costs how can we secure costs
here in terms of the the build the build
project
um well it's not really again it's not
really something that's necessarily
directly relevant to the consideration
of plan application um I think
tangent um the build cost as I
understand it of what's proposed now
is significantly lower say than a
traditional build cost structure but I
think that that's probably driven by
circumstances up to this point and the
amount available to actually produce the
building itself uh but again I don't
think as a direct planning issue that's
relevant I think we we we're considering
really whether the building as a new
structure is appropriate in that setting
um as a new addition in
itself thank you councelor Club I think
yet again these are questions you may be
better off asking Le Lee carel I think
many of these things are Beyond U what
the planning offices remit would be um
you agree with me
there you right chair and I think uh
particular the last question I I don't
even think that you could ask the
applicant if you want but it's it's just
not planning consideration cost if it
overruns then you know the applicant may
have to come back with a different
scheme at some point we just look at the
planning
merits okay
okay
okay thank you Bradley we may have to
come back to you yet because we may not
be getting the right answers from where
we want them but we'll try
Okay public speakers we have no no Town
Council no objector no supporter we do
have Lee Carell as the agent acting on
behalf of the council and I understand
you're not planning to to to make any
presentation but you're willing to ask
answer questions as as as some when they
arise and I think that's their time now
who wants to kick
off councelor
gron thank you um hello Lee um I have
some question questions from before
regarding the uh prevention of
vandalism both the
external um building from graffiti and
other similar vandalism and even gouging
as it would um you know people putting
their gouging out their their initials
and that kind of thing um and
also are the lose Lo able from the
outside so that hopefully when the
facility or the park is closed um the
prevention of vandalism because I think
the changing Place facilities in
particular contains quite expensive
equipment um can you tell me what what
the prevention um activities are there
please thank
you um so um thanks for that question so
essentially um improved security is uh
Paramount um in the thinking not just
for the this element of the park
improvements but the wider program
that's being planned for the park um so
in terms of um the treatment and the
Finish um as Bradley's picked up um
Timber clad is the proposal at this
stage however we would be more than
happy to have a condition on that for
the final treatment to be conditioned if
the planning Authority think that's
appropriate we have also looked at
Composite Materials as well what we're
very keen to make sure is that the
durability the performance and the
actual aesthetic of the of the Finish
are befitting the park um location which
is obviously featured through the
pre-application work we've done with the
Heritage officer as well um but we'd be
more than happy to clarify that we
haven't really got into that level of
detail with a contractor at this time
but we we we would be more than happy to
produce that to the planning Authority
by way of
condition um other measures the the park
itself has had an upgrade in terms of
the CCTV coverage recently is part of
the Town network of
CCTV um we would be Keen to extend the
CCTV coverage as well to improve the
security actually at the location um
which we will negotiate with the
operator we're actually going out to
procure an operator um this week
providing we we can get a um a planning
consent through so um that's something
we will be looking to improve um and in
terms of the vandalism one of the other
things we've considered is the the
actual um solar PV generation because
there is a direct current and potential
dangers from people tampering or um any
vandalism or um climbing on the the
structure itself so we've we've actually
upgraded the um safety of the CC of
sorry of the PV system so that there'll
be automatic cut out if people did climb
up vandalize or tamper with they're not
going to electrocute themselves because
of the kit that we're going to be
putting in so hopefully that does give
some reassurance and obviously the
presence of an operator there the
lighting and the the house itself is
going to be the Belleview house will be
converted into two residential dwellings
that will improve that General
monitoring of the park outside of its
opening ours as well so we're hopeful
that as a package of improvements um we
we can uh we can we can improve the
safety and the fear of crime and
antisocial Behavior at the park um but
if someone does want to Dam damage and
vandalize um it's it's quite difficult
to stop them and because there's quite a
lot of glazing as well in the in the um
uh Cafe to let natural light and
ventilation Etc there will be roller
shutters over the glass areas as well
just to make sure that they're not
broken did you
say did you say there
are the loser lockable from the outside
and that's quite they will be um public
realm vast I think there's a system can
get in place which will basically lock
them at a certain time so before the
park closes that they can be
automatically locked they will be
lockable from the outside and the actual
um exactly as you said because the
change in place is such a high
specification and with very specific kit
in there the key for that will be
retained by the operator of the cafe so
when so similar to like radar Keys have
operated historically where people will
get this key and use the toilet and then
deliver that back so we'll we'll make
sure that that's in the operator uh
remit for for making sure that that's
properly controlled and
supervised yes and yes cuz externally
you've got quite a difficult problem as
you said because you want the Aesthetics
but also you've got to
prevent the place looking terrible in a
few months or years time so thank you
very much I feel um reassured thank
you canel
clover thank you chair um in terms of
Lee good morning to you the in terms of
the longevity of the Timber cladding can
you put a sort of a timeline on that and
can I just interject with a second
question as well in terms of it it it
may well be attractive for um people
some people to car climb on top of the
roof if those solar panels were put a
pitched angle would that not be more of
a deterrent so there two questions for
you there
thank you for those questions so in
terms of the longevity um the modular
units are actually pretty comparable to
traditional bill so the there's a 50 60e
life expected and again it depends on
the level of treatment that's that's
applied and the maintenance um for the
for the um facility which we will ensure
um is um is in place as well um the
design we've had to really think about
the the cost Effectiveness um the the
modules are provided in a bit of a
obviously a standard typ type of format
so it's flat roof we did look at um a a
different design with the traditional
build Cafe that was originally planned
but cost was very high um the costs that
were associated with the groundworks
there was going to need to be quite a
lot of invasive retaining structures put
in place for a traditional build which
is why it's now moved towards the the
modular design um so um as it proposed
it's it's a flat roof um and we will
look at all we'll talk to the operator
sorry the operator and the supplier as
well to make sure that we can get as
many reasonable deterrent factors in in
place as possible to to prevent and
deter vandalism but as it stands there
is a flat roof structure with PV
installed
above thank you can I just make the
point that I'm not talking about a
pitched roof design I'm just saying that
run the panels at a pitch with with uh
you know steel stanions to support
them yes we can we can certainly do the
actual Ang angle of the PV and obviously
that'll be based on optimizing this the
solar generation we think that we can
get around 4 and a half thousand
kilowatt hours from the PV that we're
proposing to install on the roof as well
so again that will give some good
efficiency and sustainability options
for the operation of the cafe as well so
yeah we'll we'll certainly pick that up
thank you thank
you Council register you in the
next
um yeah Lee uh relating to the PV do the
trees to the South limit the efficiency
of the P PV and has that been taken into
account in the calculations and secondly
for the air source heat pump one issue
raised was um again to do with potential
um security which is it being interfered
with by somebody shoving a stick through
the uh the grid uh there's I I gathered
there's a cage uh being recommended
around the air source heat pump does
that reduce the efficiency of the air
source heat
pump thank you for that um so in terms
of the security for to prevent the
access and tampering with the air sorts
heat pump we look at um there's a few
options there's cage or there's um like
a grp type unit that you can put around
it again we want it to be fitting and
blend into the setting of The Cafe so we
we're going to pick that up with the
operator and again that I think that's
been proposed as a condition that
there'll be some containment suitable
containment for the air source heat pump
so we'll make sure that that's in place
um and um we've done some modeling
historically on the sun house and the
best orientation of the um the um Cafe
to light and its aspect out towards the
house and to the play areas Etc
um so that in inevitably because of the
trees there there will probably be some
impact on the overall um performance of
the um PV but we we're going to speak to
the operator the sorry the um Supply
make sure we can optimize what we can to
to get that on there um and we've um
we've again I think it's going to be
conditioned that the PV up to a certain
kilowatt Peak will be um installed on
the on the cafe so um we we'll do the
best we can um and in terms of the sun
we've looked at the project how the the
sun moves through the year so hopefully
um we can optimize that there's not
going to be any battery storage either
just to clarify that for this quite
small scale development for the
park councel
car thank you um I had a couple of
questions if that's all right me um
going back to the toilets and the
security
um I was wondering why you're opting to
give the operator the key rather than
the radar key um because the radar key
system seems to work quite well um and
hopefully what will be a thriving Cafe
it may be slightly inconvenient for them
to be handing out keys and how would you
would you have to show a disabled badge
how would that how would that work um
also I would be quite interested to know
um councelor Hulk mentioned just a few
minutes ago about why there was no
toilet inside for staff um and what what
led to that decision um and lastly due
to it being a modular build I suppose
for transparency what is the um Lifetime
on that and what will the what is the
expected maintenance to be able to keep
it for as long as possible please thank
you okay thank you so um in terms of the
actual format of the we've not
completely bottomed out the actual
access to The Changing Places toilet um
at the moment we we'll get the most
flexible and secure option possible so
nothing is really decided in that front
yet so we could choose radar key or just
the optimal way of of making sure that
the the toilet is monitored and that
people can have as flexible access as
possible and we're also looking at a
couple of uh formalized blue badge um
parking Bays up at the front area of the
park as well to make sure that that can
be used as as flexibly as possible so we
will be able to clarify that J course
and we'll we'll speak to public real
team as well because they'll have a a
firm view on what's the best um
monitoring for the for the changing
places toilet and access for it um
toilet so we did look at internal access
to it but we were quite constrained by
the the module they come in a pre um set
size the the the the module the um units
that are put down for the cafe and
toilet block we also wanted to make sure
that we got four toilets because the
obviously the the toilets that will be
installed with the cafe for The Wider
part use as well with demolishing the
existing toilet block as well
um we did um have some comments through
from food safety colleagues it's not a
particular issue if people have to leave
just to go around the corner to use the
toilet um it was just really the um and
it's for Needum lake cafe if any of you
know that as well that's not accessible
in internally to staff as well so um it
was really just uh it doesn't appear to
be too much of a an issue um in terms of
accessing it but it was a bit more of a
configuration issue in in setting that
up to be accessible internally we wanted
all of the toilets to be accessible
externally as well for security um so
the decision was made that that would
not be accessible to staff from inside
the building that they would have to use
the out door rout as everyone else will
um so um it's just a something that the
supplier is configured into the design
as well so um this is something that's
done elsewhere as well where um staff
would access externally so um there's
really nothing else I can clarify on
that I'm afraid um and going to the back
to the longevity um modular build should
be comparable to traditional building of
respect so 50 60 years with good
maintenance regime um obviously public
realm team will no longer be maintaining
the um the the toilet block that's
regularly vandalized and dilapidated
they'll have the new um toilets to to um
be able to support um also we're looking
at what can be done with the cafe
operator to keep the daytoday running
and maintenance and supplies of the
toilet in good order as well to make
sure that that's CU they obviously new
operator coming in will be benefiting
from a brand new facility that's will be
on there and it's really important that
we keep it in in good order um so that
will form a bit of a balance between
what the operator can do and what public
realm team will be doing as well we'll
make sure everything else is in the
normal sort of Maintenance um
recommendations of the supplier as well
there'll be an operation a maintenance
manual that come with the finished hand
handed over units which we will observe
make sure fully
maintained
thank you Lee c grandon you had one
forigner question for Lee thank you two
very small points um are there going to
be outside tables and chairs and if so
um are are they going to be is it
planned that they will be um stored
internally when the Cafe is closed and
my other question is um it looked from I
don't know this is for planning or for
yourself from the pictures we saw
diagrams we saw it looked as if there
were
trees
um that block the view of this facility
from places like um Belleview house are
those trees remaining in
place thanks for that um so first
question um there will be some tables
and chairs that the op operator will be
responsible for where they'll put them
immediately outside the vicinity of the
cafe um so they will generally be stored
inside the prop premises during um
closed times um in addition public realm
team are looking at the wider
reconfiguration of play um and other
activities in the park so there will
also be some fixed seating and table
improvements over a bit of a longer
period which will not be within the
operator control that will be fixed um
improved seating which should Connect
into the part but that's not part of
this application and that will be later
on for for public realm um Works to come
so essentially in the lease agreement
with the operator they will be
responsible for both providing and
storing the tables and chairs uh for the
cafe um and in terms of the trees there
is um during the year there's regular
cycles of tree maintenance at the park
already what is happening is there's
there's some further sort of crown
raising Crown lifting and um enabling
Works to let the actual Vehicles come in
to actually deposit the the um the units
on site when they're installed so that's
being undertaken at the moment actually
so there's nothing there that's actually
prohibiting um or interfering with the
units when they're going to be placed
and also public realm have been thinning
out some of the hedging so there is a
greater aspect to see in the park the
Belleview house from the cafe in the
park so um obviously we can't there's no
trees being removed with this
application there's no need for it um
but it's just the regular um part
maintenance by public realm is
considering opening up some of the
sidelines um so that they're better
access because one of the things we want
with the cafe is that people will have
an aspect out to the play area and also
to the park so um that's um been some of
that's been done already and further
work will be undertaken with
that
councilor Osborne you had a
question thank you Mr chairman um yeah
thank you Lee for your answers to the
question so far um one of the questions
was about the uh heat pump uh which came
up at full our sub full Council and that
was a an area of of wanting to make sure
that that was
Secure um so uh the question that Tim
asked I think uh will suffice that one
the other the other question I've got is
that um there is a a high voltage cable
that runs from um cornard road
underneath what was the old swimming
pool and they put a temporary fencing up
I think it was the uh electricity board
this is a few years ago now and I would
like you to ask public realm uh to have
a look at that uh amount of um temporary
um well not scaffolding but those areas
that they they put up because the brick
wall fell down so we're talking about
we're talking about 14 years ago and
they still haven't done anything uh it
is a way in for people because they've
removed one section so any vandalism
which in the park has caused during the
evenings when the Park's locked up as
Council Grand is uh alluded to um I
would like you to ask public realm if
they can do something about that because
it is a dangerous a dangerous area for
them to come into plus the fact they
they will cause problems when they get
in the Park thank
you um just to clarify thank you for
that Council Osborne um the the whole
stretch along cornard Road does need
some Works um that it's it's a very
variable picture across that whole
stretch of cornard road different levels
there's some some quite um decent
reinforcements still there but equally
there's bits that are that are not so it
does need to be tackled so I'll
certainly raise that with public realm
and just for some further reassurance we
do have UK PM Works um enabling Works
already order on order we're going to
upgrade the electricity Supply to three
phase because the cafe does require it
so that will also give some more
flexibility in the park and we got an
engineer down there so we've already
raised the fact that there was previous
um temporary Works done and and
potential issues with cabling there so
they they'll be looking at that when
they come out on site over the next few
weeks
yeah I believe the cable in it goes
under there because it's high volage is
three phase so um it the problem I've
got is the section of of the section of
the U temporary fencing that went in the
metal fencing which has been removed one
section has been removed and that has
given access to anybody and it's a
dangerous way of going in that part
thank
you
Council
CR thank you um I'm not sure who this
question would be for um it's about um
the potential for bats in the existing
public toilet block looking at the bat
survey that was done only the old garage
was actually surveyed they did an
emergence survey of the old garage but
not I can't find any evidence that
there's been an thatat emergence survey
done of the toilet block but I might be
missing something and obviously because
this is going to be demolished um it
needs to be considered although the
preliminary preliminary ecological
report said that it would be of low
roosting potential for bats I just
wondered if that was going to be
done Lee is that one that you might take
we provided work that was undertaken
with the previous planning applications
for the park entrance work um I think
the proposal at the moment is to
incorporate Wildlife friendly Li in Etc
but there's no nothing that's been done
in terms of specifically that survey
beyond that that's already been provided
with the
application um we understand as well
that the ecology report the preliminary
ecology report does mention um low
potential for B roosting in that area
and there's also a reference to Badger
um assessment which we will be
undertaking as well before we
commence CH sorry could I just just had
for the counselor the um one of the
recommended conditions is that prior to
commencement a uh a further survey for
protected species takes place which was
recommended by the ecological consultant
so that would pick up um the issue with
relation to any B uh presence within the
the existing
building councelor h
sorry Lee I've got quite a few things I
want to say um have you got a license e
for the calf
yet no we're going out for an operator
um starting actually this Friday for one
month period inviting bids and also
looking at the uh potential benefits of
having a social value operator in the
park to benefit the park community and
events and um engagement with some of
the people that use the park in the
current climate obviously with things as
they are it might be difficult to get a
licy and the last thing we want to see
is an empty building with a lovely set
of new
toilets if it's an economic question
there isn't there as to whether a lensee
will accept running the cafe in the
current conditions that we have what
we've tried to do um Council of H is to
put a put together a quite an attractive
package which is is waiting that social
benefit of having a good um Community
interested um um operator in the part
not just the purely financial gain so
we're hope hopeful of getting some some
interesting pits in with leaving it
deliberately quite flexible um what
we're also Keen to make sure is that
elements such as perhaps monitoring the
toilets cleaning the toilets is not
going to be a deterrent to any bidders
coming forward so we've tried to strike
that right level and we will remain
flexible during the process of securing
an operator um we have had some historic
interest in running the cafe in the park
as the the previous iteration of the
work was done so uh we're hopeful um but
you're you're right in the current
climate it's it's going to potentially
be quite challenging so the council will
do what it can to make sure we get
someone in place to to uh I suppose it
opens a question up as to whether the
the district council and the Town
Council might have to contribute to the
operating of the of the cafe in the long
term or short
term um if I can move on to something
else can can I make sure that some of
these questions are drifting away a
little bit from from a planning plan we
are is the planning do respect CH it's
always the case when it's our own
application because we've I think we've
all got our heads in other things as
well and considering other things but I
do appreciate your comment we're here
for planning and planning only please um
one of the other things um in the in the
application was the 5-year plan for the
park uh I know one of the key drivers
originally with the cafe was the under
five's play area being moved so it was a
adjacent to the seating area of the cafe
so that young parents could go with
their children they could sit at the
cafe in decent weather their children
could play in quite Clear View again
little bit concerned the 5-year plan is
very open-ended um it mentions the
underes play area but it doesn't give
any
specifics and again it's a it's it's one
of those USPS for it that if you've got
the play area adjacent to the cafe it
would encourage young mothers to go in
young parents to go in grandparents to
to go in with their children
grandchildren so that they can sit enjoy
the benefit of the cafe the benefit of
the park and it's again it's not
particularly a key plan issue but again
it builds to the overall
um design and concept of the cafe so is
there any guarantees or anything you can
give me today that will encourage me to
believe that the under five's play area
is one of the key things that is on the
public realm team's agenda to get done
sooner rather than
later I hope I can do that um yeah we've
been um Consulting with public real
colleagues throughout this whole process
and I can give some reassurance to the
committee today that um the underes play
area reconfiguration is the top priority
for exactly those reasons um the whole
Cafe um and toilet um project has been
in response to public feedback and
engagement at the park and one of the
key drivers for it was exactly that that
parents and uh grandparents and
Guardians will be able to supervise
their children whilst having a CO coffee
or um a snack at the cafe um and so um
public realm are prioritizing this as
the first um significant reconfiguration
step that will come forward um I would
also just say that um the 5-year plan
has slipped a little bit in terms of
some of the activities on there because
it was um obviously a lot has changed
with BW Park Park the significant
Churchill retirement complex um has not
has stopped so there's just been a
little bit of reordering so the under
fives is coming forward as as the
priority okay chair if I could touch on
the we' mentioned vandalism and the
security of the site obviously you
mentioned the the church application and
even the current sub Town Council uh
preference would be to open the front of
the park obviously that would bring the
cafe into more clearer view of public
view um um its location at the moment is
as is the toilet quite hidden um and is
susceptible to vandalism you've touched
on various methods and things you may do
to tr try to mitigate that um and you
mentioned the PV panels on the
roof will we just put the PV panels on
the roof as a tick boox even if they're
not efficient enough to actually benefit
it because Council reg rightly mentioned
about the shadowing if they're not going
to generate sufficient energy why do
them because to me that is a vandal
vandalism waiting to happen and you'll
probably then end up having to secure
the roof height with bar wire or
something like that which we don't want
it needs to be open it needs to be
welcoming so I just like to ensure that
you don't put PV on it just because
that's what people want if it's not
efficient is and it's going to deliver
enough energy for it to Warrant to be
there because it would just be another
vandalism aspect of the site
unfortunately we can't get away from the
fact it's it's currently It suffers
extreme vandalism at periods of time um
and you touched on
CCTV I'm sure we could
relocate add an additional I know we
struggled to put a camera in the par and
get it installed but I'm sure we could
get another camera solely for the cafe
so that I I wouldn't have thought it was
that difficult speak to West suff to
enable them to facilitate that um so
that's another thing on there
the old toilet block you mentioned
removing it is going back to open uh
space um the awful bit of land behind
the the fencing which we've been and
seen many a time I take it there's no
plans currently or is their plans in the
fiveyear plan to address that because
again that that's an ugly site that is
fenced off that is is deric behind it
that is not welcoming and any
improvements to that um again through
public realm would be appreciated but
whether you can comment on
that okay um so starting with a PV
um it's important for the sustainability
to have some PV on the roof um and we've
actually going to have more on there um
than is needam lake cafe so um there's
there was two options one was was
complete Overkill um but this one is
proportionate so I think it's 5.6
kilowatt Peak or thereabouts um so we're
confident and because of the technology
that's going to be used they they they
do generate still even we're partially
covered um so we've put so similar to
the technology we've put on the carports
where individual panels um are obscured
or something it the whole performance of
the whole system is actually much
greater than any Years Gone by because
the technolog is better um so we we
believe it's more than a sort of token
Chester really and that will also give
some benefit to the operator obviously 4
and a half ,000 of uh kilowatt potential
hours per anom it's equates to about
1,400 1500s potentially of of reduced uh
electricity bill so it's it's worth
doing um CCTV um absolutely we we will
look at all options to get full coverage
and some internal coverage as well which
is something we do want to discuss with
the operator and obviously we'll pick up
with the town Network as well see where
we can get an additional camera again we
did it with the car ports we've got CCTV
with the car ports to prevent and deter
vandalism as well so that seems to be
working
okay um and what was the last one sorry
I forgot there the last question
was
um oh yeah sorry the The Wider plans to
open up the par so um there there was a
a consented planning application for um
a a significant accessible um new park
entrance more round to cornard Road
that's not progressing due to cost and
because it was reliant on the Church
Hill um deal so that's not going ahead
we have been in discussion and we do
continue to seek to work in partnership
with sub Town Council around all
opportunities to bring forward a better
accessible entrance and to make it much
more visible to people visiting the town
because the the the park is tucked away
it's not greatly um signposted so we're
looking at all options there with the
with the Town Council um however at the
moment it's quite difficult because of
the levels difference any significant
regrading of the site there is going to
cost quite a lot of money at the moment
so we're just going to look at what we
can do and and also external funding
bids for example um Heritage lottery or
other options that might help us to to
bring forward a better part but
temporarily where that the the toilets
are going to be demolished it will be
put be put back to hard standing or
grass for a
temporary time until a fuller solution
is found for the park entrance just a
couple other things is mainly to do with
access to the site I assume doing the
development it will be from England Well
Road which is quite sufficient to take
in I believe they mentioned the paper
transits would be the type of vehicle
that would deliver I can't see how
that's going to deliver in the modules
but um I'm sure you can Enlighten us on
that and then you mentioned blue badges
uh blue badge parking where where were
you thinking of having blue badge
parking so um there's actually been a
meeting today to just with the the
parking manager to look at um where the
current access is to the old pool site
there's some informal parking people
been parking there so we're looking at
formalizing those into blue badge maybe
two or three spots there it's still a
little walk down to the cafe and the
toilet but it's the best we can do at
the moment until there's a full solution
for the new
entrance um and in terms of servicing
the cafe standard sort of vehicles
will'll access no problem and for the
actual access to install the
prefabricated units we've been on site
with the supplier they've done all the
calculations the sweat path from both
they could they think they can actually
get him from Newton Road as well as
Ingram well they can definitely get in
from ingrams well so there's no craning
or anything of that nature needed to
install on the site so that's good news
and one last thing chair the cafe block
the current one will it be demolished
and removed and is the licy you've
obviously had discussion with the person
who's runs up um we don't see that there
there'll be um a need for for two um
outlets in the park however the there's
a leas in effect for the current um the
cabin up the other end of the park
that's really to be resolved at the
moment and it's it's going to be down to
that operator as well what their plans
are so we'll we'll um and they have an
opportunity to bid if they wish to for
the for the new Cafe itself actually so
um nothing's off the table at the moment
but um we'll we'll try and get the right
um balance in place for the
park thank you as Clover you have one
question thank you chair yeah obviously
the design is there to maximize light
into the building but I'm just wondering
given the discussions about vandalism
and also staff and even customers having
to walk around to the L would it have
you considered the idea of a covered
walkway perhaps extended right the way
around the building so that um that
would serve two things a keeping people
dry when they went to the the the L and
but also a deterrent to vles to try and
get up above a cover and then onto onto
the
roof yes um again cost is a factor
unfortunately so um we we did look at
covered walkways um initially um and
discuss that with public realm
colleagues and we with the design and
the cost of
um and the the um the maximum budget
that we've got we haven't install
haven't proposed installing covered
walkways at this time there's nothing to
potentially deter that from being um
added on in a future period um but what
we've done is to orientate the building
so that the um the toilet block is not
one of the other options was to put it
to the back which we didn't want to have
put to the back um so we've really just
um complied with what public realm SE is
the best fit for the park at this time
as well there'll be some other things
like some sail canopies and shading um
elements that we will want to bring in
later later on but that will be a step
down the line once the the further Park
reconfiguration works are underway so um
we'll we'll keep that under review but
there's no plans to put a covered
walkway at the at the moment
thank
you thank you Le councelor Brandon you
had a quick question yes um is the cafe
planned to be open all year um or core
hours and if it is open any part of the
year or only core hours what will happen
about opening and closing the
Le so the intention is that the um the
Cafe will be open all year when the
parks open all year and also ability for
evening events and activities again
which should benefit some of the
security issues in the park if it's in
use um and also to um generate an
additional Community program and
activities for people using the park so
we're quite Keen to do that and that's
something that we'll go into the it was
in the operator brief something we want
to work with the operator on um so
um um that's something we want to
progress and obviously the park has
significant events like Party in the
Park the Carnival's been there before so
we want the the cafe to be part of that
um um that offer in the park as well so
um that's what we're looking to do um
and in terms of um some of the other um
benefits we we will explore the
opportunity of the cafe operator opening
the park or locking the park up but
that's we've got to be a little bit
careful not to passport all of the
responsibility all the liability for
some of this onto the operator and that
would be essentially be a bit of a
deterrent we think so there's
discussions to be had in that respect
but the toilets we want them to be
lockable at a set time the technolog is
there that they could all be shut when
the park shuts by some sort of mechanism
um so we'll we'll make sure that that's
um that's considered and with public
realm and these and the supply of the
units as
well
thank you Le Council H final question I
have that's no question chair it's it's
a case of I'd like to propose we accept
the officer's recommendation to Grant
full plan of permission on this
application well as we haven't opened it
up for debate yet we we do that and I'll
do it again then then you can do it
again when we do that are there any more
questions for Lee I hope we've all got
in Lee I want to thank you and thank you
for answering questions on this
application and the next half dozen
applications I think that coming in the
future um so you'll all remember you
won't have to ask these questions when
the next part of the fiveyear plan comes
in thank you very much Lee right i' now
open it a debate councelor hul do you
wanted to start the debate questions I'm
only joking um I'd like to uh recommend
that we accept the officer's
recommendation of approval for this
application I'm sorry that I've asked so
many questions about a fiveyear plan but
I think the questions were valid and
important especially for people in sub
thank
you
we have to canc GR in you're seconding
so we have a proposal in a
second one one
moment I'm gathering from the debate
that there's possibly one extra
condition that you talked about which
was involving um vandalproof paintt or
surfacing off off the building however
we may phrase that um we can we can
fashion a condition to that end um we
need to speak to obviously the applicant
about how it work if you can get a
particular sort that works on Tim
it seems that most of those do work on
hard surface not on Timber but there are
such treatments
so yeah one would it should be it looks
like there are Clear Solutions so so it
should be possible so I think you're
asking for a vandalproof
surfacing wording to that
effect are you happy with that councelor
hold
um well as you've been asking so many
questions and we've sort of been
crossing the tees and dotting the eyes
all morning I I think it does no
harm Le would have done that anyway okay
thank you we have a pose on the table
canoun car you have do I to the proposal
or you have another I jump in with a
quick
question to who to
Lee well Lee are you willing to take one
last question sorry Lee
thank you um asking about if there's a
um construction management plan in place
um to look at the the impact please
sorry there will be um the um supplier
um PK will be providing that it will
also include engagement with public
realm team in terms of separating and
minimizing any impacts on the A and
obviously during demolition of the to
current toilet block there'll be a plan
in place to make sure that that's done
safely and that um minimum necessary to
um ensure the park users can still
access the park while that's going on
and the modular design will should
hopefully mean that the actual time on
site is a lot less than if we were doing
a full foundations and invasive Works
program so that will be provided
yeah councilor Carter there's there is a
condition proposed on that so that is
already
covered thank you
thank you chair in in the absence of
obviously we're GNA have a relatively
short debate um and it's hard to fault
the planning side of it it all seems
quite straightforward and toilet Etc um
if I was an investor in this business
I would feel that there's a high degree
of Jeopardy in the project that's on the
table and I think it's only fair to say
in the council's current uh financial
situation um we should be considering
the sustainability projects like this
such that we aren't sort of pushing
ourselves into situations where a we
don't seem to have uh an agreement with
anyone to take this project on there's
quite a high degree of risk for the
people that are taking the project on
and yeah I mean I think it's it's it's
it calls into question the
sustainability of the
development uh yeah I just want to make
two comments one was about the toilets
and uh the staff using the public
toilets um I can confirm that from n
went from 1976 to 1984 when I worked at
B at bevie par for baby District Council
all our staff used the public toilets
even though we had sheds behind where
the pumping shed is now and worked all
over including at the putting shed which
is now the current
Cafe um so I don't see a problem with
the staff from the cafe using the public
toilets because it used to happen quite
happily before and worked and the park
ranger even up until the late '90s when
there was a park ranger used the to
youth public toilets as well um uh the
other point was that the current Cafe
operator I think is due to retire so it
may not be an issue you have to consider
and the third issue third point is CCTV
if you if you bring in an operator puts
in their own equipment I would have
thought that operator would want to put
their own CCTV which is actually really
cheap to do now uh you could put CCTV
which would obviously improve security
of the uh the whole block so I I
consider all three issues of nonre
really
non-issues and that's all I wanted to
say very quick one um under the
construction management plans
particularly with the Demolition I take
it would be the standard uh standard
conditions no burning on site Etc than
you Council Hall you have a proposal do
do you want to add to it or subtract one
comment really just uh Council wman
mentioned the the the feasibility of it
and he's absolutely right but I think
what what sub will gain is is a new
toilet block and uh that that is
essential uh it's not that funny um it's
essential I think for the park to have
that refreshed up dated so yes it may
come at a small liability but um or
bigger liability than just a toilet but
um it's definitely needed within the
park okay we move to the vote as we have
a proposed in a second uh can I get the
area manager P just to clarify exactly
what the resolution is than thank you
chair it the recommendation is as per
the report um the conditions are on page
uh what page is that hold
on page
21 of your pack um with the added
condition relating to um an a Vandal
Proof
surface have you got that that way an
anti Vandal
surface thank you chair members that vot
is now in progress in modg
thank you chair that is 10 votes for so
that is unanimous it's a unanimous
decision I thank you all I thank all
those attendance um I I'll close the
meeting by telling you the next meeting
is on the 24th of January but the the
area manager has has informed me that we
might be struggling to
get any business for that one nothing
scheduled but thank you everyone next
meeting 24th of January I now formally
close the
meeting